[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 très heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale voici les titres de ce mardi 12
novembre d'immigrants de plus en plus
jeunes accompagnés dans les yvelines
l'un des constats du dernier rapport
annuel du secours catholique sur la
pauvreté en france dans département ce
sont en tout 27 mille personnes qui sont
soutenus par l'association des zooms
dans cette édition sur le métier
d'ascensoriste profession qui gère
l'installation la modernisation et la
maintenance de 560000 ascenseur sur le
territoire un centre forme les
professionnels attrape le délégué
interministériel à l'apprentissage s'est
rendu sur place
et puis revivre la rencontre entre de
gaulle et eisenhower de 1959 au château
de rambouillet c'est le principe de
secret défense
une pièce immersive et participative qui
sera jouée en juin prochain plus de 600
bénévoles
ils seront associés avant de développer
ces titres le tribunal d'instance de
rambouillet a évacué ce matin par les
pompiers 70 personnes environ ont dû
quitter les lieux suite un important
dégagement de fumée d'après nos
confrères de 7,8 actuelle incendie
serait dû à la surchauffe d'une prise
électrique la rue gambetta où se situe
la cour qui juge les affaires civiles a
été fermée aujourd'hui à la circulation
un mot de politique samedi les adhérents
de la république en marche se sont
réunis à l'occasion d'un campus à
villepreux l'objectif échanger et et
définir une ligne directrice pour les
prochaines élections municipales les
détails de michael et demi d'euros une
journée pour se mettre en marche en vue
des municipales ce samedi 9 novembre les
adhérents et militants lrm des yvelines
se sont réunis autour d'un campus à
villepreux
l'objectif lancé officiellement la
campagne définir une ligne directrice
c'est important pour déjà bien définir
l'application concrète de ce qu'on
promeut comme valeur comme
comme idée de la politique locale et
surtout de pouvoir échanger ensemble sur
les problématiques communes qu'on
rencontre et partage et merci aux leçons
pour échanger plusieurs ateliers d'une
heure étaient organisées sur le site
tout au long de la journée au programme
des thématiques sur l'écologie
l'éducation encore l'urbanisme
c'est aussi la méthode de la république
en marche un c'est que dans notre dans
notre projet progressiste il ya cette
méthode qui est basé sur la construction
et sur le travail en proximité avec le
terrain
donc on arrive avec aucune idée
préconçue et l'idée de la journée c'est
que chacun puisse s'exprimer
au total plus de 200 militants et futurs
candidats se sont réunis autour de ces
ateliers par milieu de nombreux jeunes
je suis venu pour me former pour sur
divers sujets on a tous une appétence
donc selon notre profession nos études
mais on n'est pas compétent surtout donc
je suis venu pour apprendre
on a la chance de pouvoir profiter de
retour d'expérience des personnes qui
ont déjà fait campagne ou qui se lance
en ce moment en tant que candidat ou
chefs de file donc c'est venir ici pour
partager des expériences diverses
après une journée des changes le campus
est clôturée par une séance plénière le
département compte près de treize mille
adhérents de la république en marche et
une centaine de comités locaux
[Musique]
une hausse de l'extrême pauvreté une
précarisation de plus en plus importante
des migrants sur le territoire constat
du dernier rapport du secours catholique
paru en fin de semaine dernière pour en
parler et caroline le jargon soir dans
ça vous êtes coordinatrice du secours
catholique caritas france dans les
yvelines alors il apparaît dans ce
rapport que c'est en ile-de-france que
la proportion des personnes en grande
précarité la plus importante est ce que
dans les yvelines où l'association
soutien de plus de 27000 personnes le
constat d'augmentation est aussi est
aussi le même est ce que c'est une
réalité
oui tout à fait on constate d'abord que
effectivement ce sont les femmes isolées
qui sont toujours les premières victimes
de la pauvreté
mais cette année on a constaté également
une un rajeunissement net de la
population qu'on rencontre dans nos
d'accueil que ce soit des couples avec
enfants mais aussi des hommes seuls sans
enfants qui viennent de plus en plus
jeunes dans nos accueils on fera un
focus sur la sur les migrants et sur des
ces migrants aussi qu'ils sont de plus
en plus jeunes dans un instant c'est une
augmentation de la pauvreté mais aussi
de l'extrême pauvreté la nuance quelle
est elle lalanne y installer en au
dessus ou en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
donc effectivement là on a de plus en
plus de personnes qui peinent à avoir
un logement stable parce qu'ils n'ont
pas du tout les moyens d'accéder à ce
logement et de pas de revenus suffisants
pour pour y accéder c'est ce sont les
explications comme on explique justement
cette augmentation
comment l expliquer la baisse des
revenus déjà la baisse des allocations
le manque de logements sociaux sur le
marché qui ont qu'il entraîne une
précarisation des ménages puisqu'ils
n'arrivent pas à accéder à un logement
et du coup se retrouve dans un
hébergement d'urgence
voilà la baisse aussi de l'accès à un
emploi stable et pérenne on va notamment
que même des personnes qui sont dans un
emploi depuis plus de deux ans viennent
dans nos accueils et nous présente des
factures d'impayés de voilà donc on voit
que même quand on a eu un travail
aujourd'hui ça suffit pas à plier tout
ce qu'on appelait dans la vie finalement
il ya une diversité profile aujourd'hui
malheureusement dans les personnes que
vous accompagner oui tout à fait alors
avec c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un focus
cette année sur la population migrante
mais on a à la fois des comme je vous
disais des familles avec enfants mais
aussi donc des mères isolées et puis des
hommes seuls
de plus en plus jeunes dans ce rapport
une partie analyse la situation des
personnes étrangères migrants que la
plupart des déclarent rencontrer
aujourd'hui par les 60 équipes locales
du secours catholique dans les yvelines
sont sont justement ces ces personnes
étrangères et migrants tu sais ça on a à
peu près deux tiers des personnes qu'on
rencontre dans nos accueils sont
effectivement d'origine étrangère
certains sont là depuis assez longtemps
parfois même plus de 10 ans et leur
difficulté ressemble un petit peu à
celles que rencontrent les personnes 2
française donc comme je disais
difficulté d'accéder à un emploi stable
difficultés d'accès d'un logement etc
mais on a aussi des personnes qui sont
là depuis moins de deux ans donc pour
eux les conditions sont extrêmement
difficiles puisque très certainement ont
très peu de revenus ou pas du tout de
ressources et ont du mal à avoir un
droit au travail un statut légal
instable et sans compter la barrière de
la
aussi qu' une difficulté supplémentaire
c'est un aidant ces personnes lui aussi
une augmentation du nombre de jeunes
c'est de plus en plus de jeunes qui sont
concernés
alors jeunes effectivement il ya un peu
plus de 18 ans mais on a de plus on rend
compte nous de plus en plus de moins de
18 ans et certains sont pris en charge
par le département par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et d'autres pour différentes
raisons n'ont pas cette protection là et
on se retrouve à devoir les accompagner
mais le cas notamment des mineurs non
accompagnés 400 sont reconnues comme
telles par le tribunal de versailles
tout à fait mais un certain nombre ne le
sont pas on n'arrive pas encore à avoir
vraiment les chiffres exacts sur ceux
qui ne sont pas rencontrés m'ont sec
aujourd'hui autour de la verrière il ya
vingt jeunes qui sont à la rue sans
solution d'hébergement par exemple donc
ça c'est le constat maintenant les
solutions comment le secours catholique
justement accompagnent ces personnes
quels types d'actions sont déployés sur
le territoire
alors on a des permanences d'action
daksi d'accompagnement administrative où
on essaye d'expliquer aux personnes
quels sont leurs droits comment elles
peuvent y accéder
leur donner les moyens d'y accéder en
tout cas ensuite on a beaucoup de cours
de français
on a 150 bénévoles impliqués dans cette
action là on propose aussi aux personnes
et aux jeunes notamment de s'impliquer
dans des actions collectives comme
d'activités culturelles mais aussi
sportives et on a récemment d'ailleurs
participé à une caritas cup qui était
une une coupe de foot national organisée
par le secours catholique du pipeline
que vos lits le parti mouvement avec des
jeunes mineurs non accompagnés
donc voilà on
on leur permet aussi de s'impliquer
bénévolement dans nos actions et
certains d'entre eux sont notamment
bénévoles à trappes dans un hébergement
d'urgence n'est pas viable deruda les
personnes qui ont été aidées par le
secours catholique aujourd'hui s'engager
et aide à leur tour oui tout à fait on a
ce cas là il y en a même qui prennent
des responsabilités qui prennent en
charge
voilà une équipe locale une action en
particulier est lui aussi un travail
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
question du logement aussi du travail le
logement le travail ça oui aujourd'hui
ces deux clés essentielles pour pour
l'insertion
justement c'est ce que nous catholiques
ont longtemps c'est effectivement bas
pour ces jeunes mineurs effectifs sont
pas tous mis à l'abri donc certains sont
pris en charge tomber dans des
dispositifs d'hébergement d'urgence
certains sont dans des hôtels un peu
livrés à eux mêmes ensuite non les
accompagne vers l'obtention d'un contrat
d'apprentissage en vue d'une meilleure
intégration
voilà mais tout ça c'est quand même un
travail de long terme
les bénévoles sont pas forcément très
nombreux aussi pour pour remplir tout
c'est tout cet accompagnement là et
c'est de la responsabilité du conseil
départemental de toute façon avant tout
d'eux dit répondre et mme effectivement
le logement c'est aussi une des clés
d'intégration sauf que on a fait le
constat depuis quelques années que le
nombre de logements sociaux était
insuffisant ce qui encombre le
dispositif d'hébergement d'urgence et ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui de plus en plus
de personnes sont à la rue et notamment
des familles avec enfants vous parliez
des bénévoles 60 équipes locales c'est
ça du secours catholique répartis dans
les yeux les oui c'est ça se sentit 60
équipes locales on a à peu près 2000 et
2300 bénévoles qui sont engagés chaque
jour auprès de ces personnes là vous
avez besoin de bénévoles sont bénévoles
effectivement toujours dans toutes les
usines et on a besoin aussi d'argent de
dons et à financer les actions forcément
il faut voilà c'est ça et on rentre là
dans notre campagne de fin d'année où on
est le plus visible auprès des du grand
public je manque c'est un peu le moment
aussi de donner pour nous soutenir et
pour toutes les informations données
aussi au secours catholique un rendez
vous sur sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
caroline le jardin soit pas ses
emplettes je rappelle que vous êtes
coordinatrice pour le secours catholique
a dit
yvelines en france on compte 560 milles
ascenseur pour les gérer un corps de
métier les ascensoristes ils sont près
de 17000 en france un métier peu connu
qui cherche pourtant à recruter attrape
l'entreprise connaît forme ses futurs
salariés est dans un centre dédié dans
lequel s'est rendu la semaine dernière
le délégué interministériel à
l'apprentissage le reportage de mathilde
et demi au centre de formation connaît
thomas a débuté son cursus ascenseur il
y a maintenant six semaines
embauché en cdi comme technicien de
maintenance il s'exerce toutes les
semaines sur des maquettes on manipule
beaucoup donc sur des maquettes on
manipule aussi sur des vrais appareils
poser comme là où on a des vrais
ascenseur sur deux ou trois niveaux donc
on va faire beaucoup de recherche de
panne travaux changement de pièce tout
ce qu'on peut rencontrer sur le terrain
l'évolution des bâtiments et des
entreprises permettent à la profession
d'avoir des demandes croissantes en
recrutement un besoin d'apprentissage
pour effectuer la maintenance le
dépannage l'installation et la
modernisation des ascenseurs
c'est un métier où il n'y a pas de
chômage on n'est jamais en sureffectif
donc conforme en fonction de nos besoins
donc en fonction de l'évolution de nos
entreprises en pollution de la delà de
l'âge de départ à la retraite aussi donc
on est toujours plus égale donc il ya
vraiment un besoin
formation un métier qui attire peu de
jeunes car peu connu patrick toulmet
délégué interministériel au
développement de l'apprentissage dans
les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville souhaiterait
mettre en place un dispositif pour
recruter plus de jeunes à la sortie des
lycées
c'est vrai qu'on utilise tous à
l'ascenseur dès fois plusieurs fois par
jour moi il m'arrive d'utiliser au moins
dix fois par jour et on sait l'utilité
les ascenseurs et on sait aussi des
inconvénients quand il est en panne donc
aujourd'hui pour qu'on trouve des
solutions
que ce soit de lille à marseille mais
qu'on puisse envoyer des nouveaux
techniciens former des jeunes dans ces
métiers une formation gratuite qui
permet d'acquérir l'ensemble des
compétences requises pour devenir
technicien ascensoriste la profession
aimerait 2000 nouveaux recrutements
avant fin 2020 définir son projet
trouver des artisans qualifiés et agir
pour la rénovation énergétique le salon
dédié revient ce dimanche pour une
troisième édition c'est à la maison des
associations de chevreuse
il est organisé par la plateforme
repères habitat et là l'ex kayes pour en
parler tiffany bio bon soir concert
chargée de mission énergie à l' agence
locale de l'énergie et du climat de
saint quentin en yvelines alors pour la
présenter l accompagne dans les
démarches de sur la transition
énergétique
c'est ça donc on accompagne les
particuliers les communes des
collectivités elle est très petite
entreprise sur toutes les questions de
transition énergétique
donc c'est à la fois les particuliers
les professionnels si ça et du coup
l'accompagnement par exemple pour les
communes et ce qu'il y en a de plus en
plus qui sont intéressés celles qui font
la démarche de venir vers vous ça dépend
ça dépend certaines ne connaissent déjà
sinon on essaye toujours pouvoir
d'agrandir d'aller toujours vers de
nouvelles communes donc en fait le
principe c'est qu'on a un conseiller qui
est partagé entre divers commune donc
avec des factures avec les informations
sur les bâtiments
on peut détecter lesquels sont
énergivores anormalement énergivores et
puis proposer des des préconisations
écoutez particulier ce qu'il ya de plus
en plus de personnes aujourd'hui qui
sont intéressés par cette thématique de
la rénovation énergétique
alors on voit que ça fluctue pas mal
avec les aides
les aides gouvernementales donc en ce
moment il n'a pas mais on a beaucoup on
a beaucoup d'appels où elle suit lé au
dernier aux dernières annonces après une
tendance sur sur le long terme
bon bah on nous espérer d'autant qu'il
ya eu des annonces aujourd'hui ce qui
est beaucoup de fraudes dans ce secteur
de la rénovation énergétique et qu'elles
annoncent aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été
faites par le gouvernement
alors là l'ex saint quentin en yvelines
et justement l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a aussi initié une
plateforme qui s'appelle repères habitat
et elle permet en fait finalement
d'avoir toutes les clés en main pour
pour faire sa rénovation énergétique
faire ces travaux
oui c'est ça alors leur père habitat
c'est vraiment l'accompagnement qu'on
propose aux particuliers
donc ça consiste à en premier un rendez
vous avec un conseiller délai court on
va pouvoir exposer la problématique en
fait soit on a des travaux à faire et
puis rossi bas ce serait bien d'isoler
en même temps ou alors c'est parce qu'on
n'a des consommations excessives ou
anormalement chaud anormalement froid
dans son logement est là donc on va
faire un premier à nous un premier
rendez vous donc pour préparer le projet
avait il expliqué toutes les
alternatives aux particuliers ainsi que
toutes les aides financières qui
existent pour pour son projet et après
en fait donc repart a dit à une charte
de qualité ou des entreprises adhèrent à
cette charte et on peut donc c'est des
entreprises qu'on connaît poursuit et
donc le particulier peut on est
transcrit harper remita peut avoir accès
à cet annuaire contacter avec six autres
prises ou pas et nous nous a pris
ensuite le chantier pour voilà voir
comment ça se passe et à la fin du
chantier il peut être valorisé avec le
concours maisons économes qui réalisait
tous les ans avec deux vélos électriques
à gagner dont on reparlera de tout à
l'heure ce que le prix du 13e concours
sera remis lors du salon de la
rénovation énergie vous l'avez dit ça
s'adresse aux particuliers cette
plateforme oui la plateforme ouïe
particulier donc maisons individuelles
ou en copropriété et du coup avec tout
cet éventail de partenaires
d'entreprises qui font partie de votre
réseau alors le troisième salon de la
rénovation énergétique je dise ça se
tient dimanche c'est à la maison des
associations de chevreuse finalement
c'est de proposer sur place
qu'ils aient retrouvé en ligne
finalement c'est la plateforme repères
habitat qui sera à retrouver sur place
je sais un peu ça oui c'est la version
physique d'accompagnement donc le but
c'est que en une journée donc le
particulier donc il va avoir accès aux
conseils en fait avec le
le conseiller d'aller comme si c'était
un rendez vous mais là en plus il y aura
d'autres
on a invité d'autres partenaires donc
notamment ont invité le partenaire
l'opérateur anad 7e et rien pour les
pour les aides financières puis aussi
des partenaires architecturaux notamment
le sait mieux de 78 ensuite tu rabat où
les artisans qui sont qui sont sur la
plateforme est alors cette année on a
aussi mis l'accent pour le retour
d'expérience de particulier parce que
bon des fois les particuliers voilà il
aime bien discuter avec nous et les
entreprises mais ça m'a bien aussi
discuter avec des personnes qui ont déjà
fait des travaux donc il y aura vraiment
la possibilité de le faire cette année
il ya deux visites qui sont organisés
donc on va vraiment chez le particulier
voir ce qui a été fait et échanger avec
lui et il y aura donc on a un speed
meeting
donc il ya plusieurs particuliers qui
vont venir chacun avec des travaux
différents
et puis le but c'est que bah voila si on
a une question si on a ça craint par un
projet qu'on à savoir comment ça se
passe comment ça s'est passé de pouvoir
échanger lors être d'avoir un suivi sur
les projets qui ont déjà été réalisés
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui hésitent encore
aujourd'hui à faire des travaux de
rénovation énergétique on rappelle que
le gouvernement a en a fait une priorité
nationale en tout cas pour la rénovation
des bâtiments
pourquoi c'est intéressant aujourd'hui
de mener des travaux de rénovation
énergétique
pourquoi c'est intéressant alors ça peut
être intéressant pour le confort
thermique
ça peut être intéressant pour réduire sa
consommation de chauffage soit pour un
aspect financier soit pour une question
de sensibilité
ça peut être intéressant pour valoriser
le patrimoine de sa maison maintenant
les enfants les personnes quand ils vont
louer quand ils vont acheter ils
regardent de plus en plus les factures
donc
donc voilà si on veut être à pouvoir
vendre plus facilement pouvoir mettre en
bonne en valeur son bien on peut
utiliser la désolation
vous avez parlé du programme du salon
c'est un parcours en trois étapes qui
sera proposée sur place de ça alors on
fait donc les trois étapes c'est un gros
préparation du projet donc là ça va
vraiment être la partie donc rencontre
avec le conseiller toutes les
associations et la partie rencontres
avec d'autres particuliers du goût qui
n'arrive qu'au salon et après il ya la
partie donc rencontre avec les artisans
et ensuite donc la troisième partie
c'est ce qu'on appelle après travaux où
ça va être la valorisation donc la
visite
et puis le concours maisons économes
donc le concours mais ce qu'on économise
va être la remise va être à midi et
en fait tous les particuliers sont
invités et peuvent voir donc les travaux
pour des travaux performant qui ont été
réalisés surtout les yvelines cette
année avec une rétrospective sur toutes
les années précédentes
donc c'est la 13e édition de ce concours
dont le prix sera remis dimanche le
juste en quelques mots pour le présenter
c'est combien de combien de maisons sont
ont été faites en compétition cette
année un peu plus d'une dizaine ça
ternit ouais donc juste sur le sud
yvelines
je suis reçue d'événements et donc le
prix sera remis sur place pour se rendre
au salon pas besoin d'inscription on
peut se rendre directement sur place
oui c'est ça alors c'est si vous voulez
pas payer sur internet et maison des
associations claude juneau là on
retrouve on trouve tout de suite dessus
c ur à partir de 10 heures jusqu'à 18h
sans interruption
voilà avec vous avez le programme sur
internet sur le site de la halle exquis
avec toutes les horaires des visites
si vous voulez participer envoyez le
site de repères habitat qui s'affichait
çà et là l'ex kiki en train de
s'afficher pour toutes les informations
sur ce 3e salon de la rénovation
énergétique je rappelle qu'il est au
programme dimanche à la maison des
associations clos genoa chevreuse merci
tiffany plutôt d'être passé en plateau
chargé de mission énergie à la lex saint
quentin en yvelines le sport la transat
jacques vabre bouclé pour louis burton
le skipper de rambouillet est arrivé ce
matin avec son coéquipier et davy
beaudart à salvador de bahia au brésil
est l'équipe bureau vallée terminé
huitième de la compétition de voile en
imoca 14 jours de traverser la transat
était parti pour rappel du port du havre
le 27 octobre dernier
une course remportée dans cette
catégorie par yann eliès et charlie
dalin sur le bateau happy via dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche à son arrivée
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
ce dimanche justement c'était la sixième
édition du grand prix de vélizy 170
cyclistes se sont affrontés sur la piste
du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et parmi eux
des jeunes en catégorie cadets et
minimes
mélanie poquet alexandre grimont n'aura
pas raté le rendez vous le jeune cadet
de l' us créteil remporte l'élimination
l'une des épreuves de l'omnium c'est la
quatrième fois qu'il participe au grand
prix de vélizy le niveau il évolue de
plus en plus chaque année donc c'est
bien pour pouvoir performer dé
s'améliorer de plus en plus
donc c'est pas un truc qui me dérange
c'est pas gagné et
on apprend une matinée réservée aux
minimes cadets et cadettes venus de neuf
comités régionaux différents et des
yvelinois avec des objectifs plein la
tête
il faut que je réussisse à les courses à
des coupes d'hiver pour partir en coupe
de france essayait de me démarquer sur
les coupes de france pour faire échapper
la france et ses membres le guide pour
ce sixième grand prix 170 coureurs ont
fait le déplacement une journée de
compétition de la catégorie minimes aux
seniors 3 épreuves différentes étaient
proposés vitesse keirin et omnium
à chaque fois on découvre de jeunes
talents et aujourd'hui les jeunes qui
sont en équipe de france sont tous
passés par le grand prix de vélizy pour
avoir une élite en france il faut donner
envie aux jeunes
et là c'est une occasion formidable
parce que nous sommes dans le vélodrome
nationale qui sera le théâtre des jeux
olympiques de 2024 et il faut faire
rêver les jeunes et courir au vélodrome
nationale là ça fait partie du rêve ce
grand prix était la première manche de
la coupe d'hiver la prochaine se tient
le 1er décembre toujours au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus de 600 bénévoles recherchés pour
reconstituer une scène historique au
château de rambouillet à une société de
production propose de revivre la
rencontre entre le général de gaulle et
eisenhower président américain au
château de rambouillet c'était en 1959
marylène iapichino vous en dit plus en
1959 le général de gaulle recevait le
président américain doit est à 9 heures
au château de rambouillet pour un sommet
d'état un événement d'envergure
internationale que polarise production
vous propose de revivre sur place
bienvenue au château de rambouillet
madame la conseillère arrivée qu'il nous
plaît je vais vous montez dans un
appartement
le spectacle est immersif toute l'équipe
vous met dans la peau d'un membre de
délégation
dans cette pièce un centre de
renseignement sera reconstituée ici il
faut imaginer arriver dans un espace
comme celui ci avec les bandes
magnétiques les écouteurs les grands
tableaux qui permettront de raconter au
public
quelle était la situation de la france
en 1959
le début du programme nucléaire les
événements évidemment en algérie aussi
la situation de berlin qui pose problème
à cette époque là le public est vraiment
amener au coeur du sommet dans les
coulisses d'un sommet d'état et de pièce
en pièce
il va suivre l'évolution de ceux de ce
sommet par ici madame la conseillère
voici la réserver aux délégations
étrangères pour que le spectacle nommé
secret défense soit réussie
la production recherche plus de 600
bénévoles car en plus d'être immersive
la reconstitution et participative ce
sont les habitants qui vont faire
revivre le lieu est l'histoire qu'il
contient en fonction de son temps libre
chacun peut trouver un rôle avec texte
ou revêtir un costume de figurants pour
des représentations qui auront lieu en
juin 2020 avec des projets comme les
projets de ces spectacle immersif vont
recréer ce lien on permet une
réappropriation des habitants du
territoire une réappropriation de ce
lieu patrimonial il se le réapproprient
et on les y sont acteurs aussi de la vie
de ce lieu du développement de ce lieu
après cette présentation à la presse
l'équipe du spectacle donne rendez vous
aux volontaires prêts à embarquer dans
l'aventuré vendredi 15 novembre au
château pour une réunion d'information
et un premier casting on clôture ce
journal à buc depuis le mois d'octobre
les habitants peuvent profiter d'une
salle de spectacle et qui a fait peau
neuve une commune la commune pardon à
rénover son théâtre des arcades une
scène a grandi des sièges rétractables
découverte avec mélanie poké et aurélie
11 des loges avec un accès direct à la
scène c'est l'une des principales
nouveautés du théâtre de buc la salle
utilisée depuis une quarantaine d'années
s'est refait une beauté
c'est attaquer vraiment aux problèmes de
base c'est-à-dire refaire toutes les
parties
perche
tout ce qui est électrique avoir du
matériel neuf et récentes
donc voilà et puis bien sûr essayer de
l'amortir en évitant tout ce qui est
location puisqu'avant ont joué pas mal
de matériel et l'idée c'était de
mobiliser tout le potentiel de la ville
pour partir dans cette aventure
culturelle et surtout donner une
identité culturelle à la ville de buc
donc ça a commencé tout petit on a
mobilisé des artistes les partenaires
les sponsors la ville et ya mis beaucoup
20 millions d'euros de travaux ont été
engagés sur l'intersaison la salle qui
reçoit des artistes depuis 2018 a vu sa
scène à baisser et agrandi plus de 300
spectateurs peuvent assister aux 35
dates qui font vivre la saison du coise
des dates bien régulière notamment des
événements qui sont récurrents
aujourd'hui à buc l'idée étant d'être
vraiment éclectique de répondre à tout
le monde nous aimons accueillir les
familles nous aimons et cueillir le
jeune public nous aimons accueillir les
jeunes donc on essaie vraiment de
répondre à tous les goûts
les prochains rendez vous seront magique
solidaire et drôle
une trentaine de dates est proposée au
public et l'essentiel des idées des
prochaines idées de sorties spectacles
concerts expositions à faire dans les
yvelines a retrouvé dans le 7-8 culture
c'est dans un instant voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]